senza scendere una scala da 1 a 1 da rai
uno la peggiore ricetta ma è proposta su
questo canale è uccello
ciao ragazzi bentornati in una puntata
di cucina buttata oggi giornata di
esperimenti perché perché sui social
tipo tik tok e instagram i prodotti
sociale in generale youtube che ovunque
sta spopolando questa ricetta questo
pure a in questo match c'è il senso
sarebbero in realtà niente eppure
inglese più o meno fatto con le patatine
fritte al posto delle patate che uno
pensa cazzo ci posso pensare prima è una
cosa geniale invece di spendere un euro
per un chilo di patate potevo spendere 2
euro per un pacchetto minuscolo di
patatine già fatto che stupido fondo lo
dice stupito tutti quanti e sono pronto
questa ricetta
c'è chi dice che buonissimo c'è chi dice
che fa cagare oggi vi diremo quello che
pensiamo noi ma non lo faremo come
l'hanno fatto gli altri che si sono
limitati a utilizzare la patatina
semplice noi per questa puntata di
cucina bottale riproveremo tre tipi
diversi per fare il pure con le patatine
fritte avremo bisogno di patatine fritte
al latte materno rubato la mucca e
lubrificante è per altre varianti
possiamo utilizzare latina al gusto
vivace e patatine lime e pepe rosa è
molto semplice noi abbiamo già messo
l'acqua sul fuoco ragazzi mi raccomando
se voi provate a fa sta ricetta a casa
vostra e non mi pagate anche solo per
vedere quando era assaggiate se vi piace
un no o un commento siete dei pezzi di
merda
sapete anche voi potreste essere i pezzi
di merda se guardate questo video non
siete iscritti a questo canale perché
posso dire solamente una persona
scorretta nella vita non si prenderebbe
il tempo di fare un click un click
semplicissimo poi passate i giorni a
spremersi i brufoli davanti allo
specchio sapete quanto ci vuole un botto
e io ti chiedo soltanto pochi secondi li
dovete fare il crocca il mio creek
capito quindi se vi siete iscritti e
avete fatto clic dovete scrivere qua
sotto ho fatto clic croc potete anche
aggiungere buon pure un cazzo se volete
proprio essere un po ricercati e
musicalmente avanti e niente adesso
ragazzi l'unica palla sarà aspettare che
quest'acqua bollain per tre volte a chi
ha un altre volte per tutti e tre pure
se veramente si arrivi gusto preferito
tuo forse vado sul banale
africa mio gusto preferito un po quelli
lì panna acida cipolla presente quelle
lì molto buone o le su tendini cannes e
non solo quelle con l'aceto vede
presente sale e aceto oppure lime e pepe
rosa vivono di più che un gusto che odio
con tutto me stesso e non è proprio un
corso sono le patatine fatte le regate
tu sei pazzo odio fatto di aver corrotto
con il vostro gusto di paganini
preferito tutto quanto al secondo posto
rispetto a granato sparsa può sempre
essere a gaza porre la geniale ricordo
mi faccio un altro nel frattempo ma sai
che devi fare è già vive di minchia
pareto trittico un trittico è arrivato
mi stai facendo volare o se è il più
schifoso sarà line e pepe rosa
concentrerà proveniente potrebbe essere
interessante il gusto vivace perché
capita un po forte a partiamo con le
naturali le prendiamo l'anno bollite
mamma mia è un po raccapricciante osceno
mamma mia non ci vuole tanto in realtà a
cucinarlo sapete perché sono molto
sottili però anche di parte delle
normali se le fate molto sottili si
cucinano più velocemente dove assaggiare
una critica
no non me la sento solo che adesso un po
augura ora che questa verdura
spero tanto tu sia pure
sono orgogliosissimo quando trovò le
rime mi sento de andrè nel frattempo sta
bollendo l'altra acqua cosa vogliamo
avviare il vaticano antezza esatto
depresse proprio vado a scolarle al volo
vr controllo di un sit in e questo è
quello che ci nascondono le
multinazionali hanno perso colore vai
cosa vinci come do mangiarla certo
ricorda vagamente la folla la patata non
so siculo spappolo un po di latte il
burro
raga guardate sta diventando due esse di
un po di formaggio
aggiungerei come la purezza sì d'accordo
la giunta di formaggio anarchia
mamma mia orribile che cos'è fallito
pezzetto noso non lo so mi fa paura a
favore a scriviamo tutti mica paure a
qui si capisce molto dall piazzamento
mamma è che si mangia il tuo cane questo
momento da parte dedicare graziana posso
dire che già sembra più colorata
dell'acqua vediamo se sono colorate
anche patatine dicevano niente
sciacquato tutto quanto ragazzi
mamma mia come prima ragazzi latte
burro parmigiano
a rimini
questo è ancora più acquoso come faccio
se veramente comico che mamma mia
vediamo un attimo ad aggiungere le
patatine lime e pepe rosa intanto qui
solito abominio questa è disgustosa
non lo so cosa sia successo
vabbè proveremo anche consistenze
diverse vorrei condividere con te nero
il pensiero le vivaci ma il nome di più
sbagliato dei villaggi siamo pronti con
le line madre santanchè qua bellmer do
laio noi non può nulla attacca e burro
così sembra osceno
io sono sempre stato molto i manga larga
diciamo manica larga aperto mi sembra il
miglior risultato tra quelli tra tutti è
il risultato migliore però guardano in
piatto normale line e pepe rosa e di
passaggio
la prima volta sono disgustato ragazzi è
la prima volta non c'è preferirei osceno
normale
è una cosa che mentre mangi ti togli il
gusto orribile orribile fanno provare a
vivace ma la gente c'era un buono poi
terrificante ultimo in mondi ryan
ma cosa non c'è una differenza nessuna
se non nella consistenza a seconda se
sono più liquidi o meno liquidi paese
scegliere una strada 11 da rai uno la
peggiore ricetta ma è proposta su questo
canale osceno il mondo posso proprio una
cosa vorrei provare a unire tutti pure
non solo omega pure assaggiarlo osceno
laminati prego la vittima sacrificale
se non sembra una mia paturnie raga qua
ma gli dici che sei
intanto tu vai e tenaci nemiche eppure
non l'avrei mai detto ma perché da di
niente la cosa di mais e tapioca dei
bambini patatine fritte sono provate
fatto diventare così l'abbiamo bollite e
ci sono resi conto che tutto il sapore
delle patatine fritte e all'esterno per
avremmo fatto bene ma bene l'acqua di
cottura e avremmo per assurdo fatto
meglio orribile grazie ad avere quindi
ti come sempre grazie a vita perché
sennò sembrava che è capito possibile
pazzo di turno un sapore ragazzi osceno
vorremmo andare in gattabuia tutti
quelli che hanno fatto dei bei video a
livello visivo e che hanno detto che non
buoni perché fa cacare questa roba detto
ragazzi perdonatemi perdonatemi io
voglio solamente sparire in questo
momento quindi vi mando un bacione ci
vediamo giovedì con un nuovo video
[Musica]